um we have a really really interesting
conversation to play from meet the press
that gets directly at this inconsistency
when it comes to
the senators who won in november of 2020
saying
that donald trump actually won and the
election results can't be trusted i'm
not going to put it up on the screen
again because you i i get uh i get flack
every time i do it
i sent a tweet out shortly after the
election saying something like you know
all of these republicans saying
that biden stole it
they were elected on the same ballots
where it would say senator or congress
and then on the same ballot president so
how could it be
that the trump biden results are
illegitimate but their results are
legitimate wouldn't they have to
question the legitimacy of their own
election of course they're never really
ever
held accountable for that inconsistency
until now
senator roger marshall a republican from
kansas was on uh meet the press and
interviewed by chuck todd on sunday
and in this conversation
chuck todd asks him do you believe you
were elected fair and square and he says
yeah yeah i was
and then he's asked about whether joe
biden was really elected fair and square
and he says well i i do have concerns
about election integrity
and he drops in a bunch of other coded
language that these people are now
regularly using to avoid dealing with
the truth truth and addressing these
issues substantively so we're going to
look at all of it this is close to three
minutes it's a longer clip than we
normally play but it's worth seeing the
full kind of arc of the conversation so
let's watch it and then we're gonna have
a conversation about it
uh you brought up bob dole at the
beginning we're gonna have our own sort
of tribute to him later in the show
but i'm curious of this senator
bob dole conceded the election in 1996.
the last president has not
what could the former president learn
from bob dole
well listen i i think that this is an
issue of election integrity um and i
think that's what's really important to
americans across the nation we value the
the ballot and the ballot booth we want
election integrity uh there's a lot of
controversy out there and i'm focused
right now on making making it easier to
vote and and harder to cheat i think
that's the focus right now well i want
to actually bob dole one of the last
interviews he gave was in july to usa
today he actually was asked about the
former president he said this he lost
the election and i regret that he did
but they did he had rudy giuliani
running all over the country claiming
fraud he never had one bit of fraud and
all those lawsuits he filed and
statements he made i'm a trumper i'm
sort of trumped out though
um
do you know you voted you you stood with
those that didn't want to certify the
election do you regret that now
considering all the crazy cockamamie
things that mark meadows and others were
doing
look i'm always going to stand up for
election integrity i i want to make sure
that every state obeys their own laws
and obeys their own constitution
especially in a time of crisis so that's
what's at risk for me right now is
maintaining the integrity of that
election and i want to do everything i
can going forward to make see make sure
that those elections have even more
safety valves in it that there's higher
levels of integrity americans value the
sanctity of that that ballot booth do
you believe you were uh elected fair and
square in 2020
you know absolutely i do i think kansas
has some of the tightest election laws
in the land we went back and looked
looked at that to make sure that it was
a safe and fair election so proud of our
secretary of state so proud of our
county clerks and those people that
volunteer checking the ids to make sure
that every person got one vote uh we're
just really proud of how kansas could do
it other states could look and see how
kansas does it
and do you believe that joe biden was
elected fair and square
you know joe biden was sworn into office
i called him mr president since the day
he was sworn in i still remain concerned
about election and i still remain
concerned about election integrity i i
think that that we need to go back and
look at what did the states obey their
own laws do they obey their own
constitution so there is a lot of kind
of mush mouth nonsense in there i'm
concerned about election integrity
there's lots of controversy that's one
of those things where yeah
your side created the controversy out of
thin air
and then points to the fact that
controversy exists to say well we should
really slow down because if there's so
much controversy maybe we can't trust
those results well what's the reason for
the controversy the other kind of coded
line that he uses there
is
we want to make sure that states obey
their own laws that is a garbage
pond scum argument that they have come
up with and the way that that one works
and i know some of you know it is
you hear this line all the time
states changed their election rules
without going through the legislature
and thus it is
illegal
unconstitutional
fill in the blank
this is not true there are provisions
that allow the states that changed the
make all of the parameters some of the
parameters of the election there are
provisions that allow that to be done
without going through the legislative
process in some states it was done
related to covid in others it was not
done related to covid but it was still
done and legally it is legal to do that
they insist it's not but it is
the other
kind of linguistic trick that they use
often
is when he was asked is joe bi did joe
biden win fair and square
marshall says joe biden is president and
he was sworn in
and chuck todd rightly points out that's
not an answer to the question i asked
we're not asking do you recognize that
joe biden is the president today saying
no to that is an extra level of wacky
the question is whether joe biden came
to be the president today
through an election that he really won
fair and square and so whenever they say
joe biden was sworn in and he is the
president when they are asked did he win
fair and square
they are avoiding saying he won fair and
square it's just a game that they play
and at the end of the day the game that
they're playing is if i won it's fair if
you won you cheated
even if i actually cheated no if i won
it's fair if you won you cheated it is
only hypocrisy
if you believe that consistency matters
and as we talked about earlier in the
show
they don't care about even appearing to
be hypocrites i i don't know what i was
looking at the other day
but
in the lead-up to trump winning in 2016.
i don't know how many of you remember
this
when there were good jobs numbers under
barack obama good unemployment numbers
under barack obama trump insisted that
the numbers from the bureau of labor
statistics and the uh from the be from
the bureau of labor statistics and
department of labor were false you
couldn't believe the numbers
and
within i think it was like his maybe his
first but certainly by his second or
third press briefing when sean spicer
trump's first press secretary came out
and said we just got great jobs numbers
and it was like trump's been president
three days it couldn't possibly have
anything to do with trump it's for the
previous week before trump was even
inaugurated a reporter said
trump called these numbers fake
before he was president
are they no longer fake and sean spicer
laughed through it but he said
the numbers are now very very real the
president now trusts these numbers
completely they don't even pretend not
to be hypocrites and this goes back to
my commentary from probably eight nine
months ago at this point where
they might
realize that they are lying
they might realize that they are
hypocrites they might realize that they
are holding themselves to a different
standard than they hold the left but
they don't care because they see this as
being in a moral holy war and if you're
at war much like if you're in a literal
war you might say
we might have to do some things we
wouldn't do in normal circumstances
we're going to have to accept that some
of us are going to behave horribly
because we're at war and the end the
means justify the ends it's the same
thing here
that they see
whether it's lies hypocrisy whatever
they see it as a justifiable means to an
end
they believe they are fighting for
in a moral and uh principled way and
when that's the case
how can you talk them
into behaving like normal rational
honest consistent people you can't
and that's what's going on